Speaker 1: Let's go to KC from Kansas. KC from
Kansas. Welcome to the program. Oh, what can
I do for you today? Hello.
Speaker 2: Just, you know,
more heavy stuff given the recent, you know.
Shooting that happened? Yeah. So Tucker Carlson
recently had a segment called Trans Killer.
The trans movement is targeting Christians. Oh,
boy. Nashville shooting. Do you think journalism
quotation marks that fear mongers, marginalized
groups with such a broad brush? Should it
be legal in a way? Oh, man. Germany or other
European countries would have. Well, there's.
Speaker 1: A number of questions there because,
first of all, you're using journalism in
quotes. Legally, Tucker Carlson doesn't do
journalism. He does commentary. So then
the question is a broader one, which is
can can, you know. So it's more like in
the category of this might be satire,
this might be sensationalism. This is it is the. I
think we really need legal experts to weigh in on
what even could be done before we can even really
weigh in as to what should be done, because it's
such a difficult question to answer. But I know
exactly what you're saying, which. And listen,
scapegoating is not a new technique. Right now,
the trans community is being heavily scapegoated
from all around. I hope it doesn't last forever.
But of course, when it goes away, they'll move on
to the next group. But you're asking some really
complicated questions that we really need the
legal world to answer. To answer for us.
Speaker 2: Excuse me.
Okay. Yeah. I don't know. I wish there was
just something that could be done because,
you know, they call themselves Fox News. I
know. And they make it seem like there's a
little bit of credibility when there's really.
Speaker 1: And then they get sued and then they
go, oh, listen, Tucker Carlson is an entertainer.
He uses hyperbole and exaggeration and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. You can't hold him
accountable. Nobody should believe that what
he says is factual. That's under oath in court,
what they say. And then on TV, they pretend like
it's news. Now, I'm with you, Casey.
Speaker 2: Okay. That's all I.
Speaker 1: Got. Casey from Kansas. Great
to hear from you. That is all the time I
have for today. Great to hear from a lot
of new and repeat callers. We will take
calls again. And I look forward
to hearing from many more of you.